voilà c'est pas forcément facile de
revenir sérieux sur ce plateau quand on
voit certains déguisements mais
l'ambiance était plutôt bonne même si
certains enseignants ont moyennement
apprécié on peut les comprendre bonsoir
valerie voit donc s'intéresser à
l'environnement avec vous comme chaque
mardi oui absolument et nous allons
venir parler ce soir de l'habitat
bioclimatique qui devrait donc être
l'habitat de demain pour en parler avec
nous et yoann gerbaud bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes chargé de mission énergie et
climat à la lèque agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat de magny les
hameaux vous avez participé vendredi
dernier une soirée débat dans les locaux
de l'alec et de la maison de
l'environnement une soirée pour
expliquer comment aujourd'hui l'on peut
vivre l'on doit vivre en prenant compte
de son environnement d'environnement il
va en être question de sites l'habitat
bioclimatique on m'en parle
effectivement dans un instant pour
l'instant un premier reportage dans
cette chronique environnement il est
consacré aux champignons oui aux
champignons composteur n'importe qu'elle
a le vent en poupe
on sait en ces temps de froid et
certains considèrent le champi
composteur et le compostage comme de
l'art c'est le cas de d'antoine jacobson
de du potager du roi à versailles
johanna boubakeur pardon et dix ans
quand le rencontrer
champetier composteur l'art de montrer
ce qu'il se passe à l'intérieur du
compost ce n'est pas une exposition mais
du recyclage deux champignons un grand
et un petit installé depuis octobre 2012
sur 3 ha du potager du roi à versailles
création du paysagiste claude pasquier
ils servent au compostage des déchets du
potager une forme spécialement choisis
par le paysagiste pour mettre en valeur
le travail des bactéries et des
champignons qui certes au compostage à
la fois beau et utile du compost produit
à base d'épluchures de carottes pommes
de terre de la paille et d'haricots
malade il faut un bon équilibre entre
les éléments carbonées les éléments
azotés si vous avez trop de carbone trop
de matière sèche ça va pas faire grand
chose parce que les bactéries et les
champignons vont pas trouver
leur nourriture nécessaire si vous avez
trop trop d'azoté trop de matière verte
trop de matière on va dire riche en
acides aminés en protéines on aura
plutôt tendance à avoir un compost qui
va pourrir plutôt que de se transformer
en terrain ça se fait on va dire à la
fois à l'oeil on va dire 1/3 2/3 mais ça
se fait aussi on va dire par
l'expérience une expérience et un
équilibre qui permet de ne pas se
tromper sur les aliments un maître dans
le compost la matière animale est
interdite pour ne pas attirer les
rongeurs non recyclables le bois brut et
le métal sont aussi prohibé pour que le
terreau se forment et que le compost ne
pourrissent pas la matière riche comme
la pomme de terre doit être éliminé dans
le champignon de claude pasquier un
terreau qui se forment plus rapidement
en été grâce à une meilleure température
comme pour nous on est plus facilement
actif quand il fait chaud quand il fait
froid
les microorganismes sont plus actifs
quand il fait chaud quand il fait froid
pour les passionnés d'art et de compost
il est possible d'acquérir le champignon
de claude pasquier
et champignons c'est un peu la maison
des schtroumpfs ssl pendant ce reportage
mais c'est très joli et en plus c'est
écologique et c'est important de le
faire ce compost on va s'intéresser à
une autre démarche toujours aussi
importante c'est l'habitat bioclimatique
oui les fonds vont nous le dit depuis
tout à l'heure il faut oui
il faut en tenir compte et c'est ce qui
va nous expliquer ce soir yoann gerbaud
qu'est-ce que l'habitat bioclimatique
alors l'habitat bioclimatique c'est un
habitat qui en fait s'adapte à son
environnement
c'est à dire que on va s'adapter
vraiment bio comme donc un climat local
par exemple voit sa on va
s'habituer déjà on va s'adapter déjà au
climat en fête typiquement la première
chose qu'on peut se poser comme question
c'est concernant l'habitat c'est le
climat qu'on va avoir par exemple dans
le sahara et le climat qu'on va par
exemple en norvège ne sont pas les mêmes
à partir de ce moment là on va pas faire
un habitat identique en norvège et au
sahara l'habitat bioclimatique c'est de
prendre en compte notamment cet aspect
là mais pas uniquement après on va
prendre en compte également tout ce qui
est aspect par exemple liés au
microclimat donc le microclimat c'est
climat qui est plutôt continental en
alsace et qui est plutôt tempérée
océanique en bretagne par exemple donc
ça c'est également des choses qu'on va
prendre en compte après on va s'adapter
aussi à la géographie donc est-ce qu'on
est sur un risque on est en montagne
lorsqu'on est en pleine et enfin on va
s'adapter aussi au terrain sur lequel on
va implanter la maison tous ces aspects
là sont des aspects d'environnement et
d'implantation qui sont importants à
prendre en compte dans un habitat
bioclimatique pour qu'il soit le mieux
insérées dans son environnement mais
également qu'il ait le moins d'impact
possible par rapport au milieu sur
lequel on est situé alors qu'est ce
qu'apporte un habitat bioclimatique par
rapport à nos maisons traditionnelles
alors en fait l'habitat bioclimatique
c'est un habitat qu'on va retrouver
depuis très longtemps les autres
guillemets les ancêtres nous ancêtres
faisait déjà de l'habitat bioclimatique
bien avant nous ce qu'on va pouvoir
prendre en compte par exemple l' habitat
troglodyte est un habitat bioclimatique
puisque c'est un habitat qui est adapté
au milieu dans lequel on est situé donc
des cavités des roches et c'est
l'intérêt c'est qu'ils ont plus ils
pouvaient apporter de la fraîcheur en
été parce que les pierres sont d'une
épaisseur important
du temps non mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que voilà l'habitat bio
climatique va apporter ces éléments là
l'essentiel pour la planète pour papa
non en fait ce
qui est essentielle planète c'est pas de
naulleau pas il faut pas revenir à la
bougie un lac big c vraiment d'essayer
de s'adapter et de voir comment
aujourd'hui on peut amener des choses
pertinentes malgré le fait qu'on ne soit
plus au moyen-âge ou à la préhistoire
voilà donc aujourd'hui si on parlait
d'habitat bio climatique l'intérêt ça
sera déjà de se rappeler que par exemple
le soleil tourne de l'est en vers
l'ouest et qu' il ne va pas au nord donc
du coup ça ne sert pas à grand-chose de
mettre des grandes baies vitrées au nord
qui nous nous apporterons jamais de
lumière donc qu'il veut idées et des
allemands il faut mettre les baies
vitrées au sud pour que la lumière
rentrer directement dans le logement en
hiver mais il va falloir aussi pouvoir
s'en protéger en été parce que sinon on
va avoir trop chaud en été donc par
rapport à ça on va essayer de travailler
sur les casquettes c'est à dire en fait
des avancées de toiture plus longue
parce que le soleil étant beaucoup plus
haut en été le soleil tape rassure la
casquette et ne rentrera pas à
l'intérieur du logement réchauffer le
logement mais également de la végétation
par exemple des arbres à feuilles
caduques c'est à dire qui ne perles qui
perdent leurs feuilles en hiver qui vont
laisser donc passer la lumière en hiver
mais qui vont là qui vont en fait
stockées la lumière en été vains stocker
la chaleur en été et éviter d'avoir trop
chaud en été c'est des aspects
bioclimatique dans nos habitats donc en
fait le but de l'habitat bio climatique
c'est vraiment apporter un maximum de
confort à l'être humain au sein de son
logement tout en s'adaptant à
l'environnement dans lequel on est situé
au terrain dans lequel on sur lequel on
est si ce sont des constructions dont on
a perdu le
les habitudes il construit comme ça ça
sent la ruine 70 bon sens voilà c'est
clairement du bon sens en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'après la seconde
guerre mondiale il a fallu reconstruire
le pays il a fallu reconstruire le pays
vite pour loger les gens et puis aussi
pour loger les populations qu'on a fait
venir d'autres pays pour reconstruire la
france à partir de ce moment là on n'a
pas forcément construit en prenant en
compte tous ces aspects là il fallait
quand il fallait construire beaucoup de
logements donc du coup on a fait appel à
des grands promoteurs qui ont construit
des logements à la chaîne et qui ne se
sont pas posé la question forcément de
savoir si la maison a été exposée au sud
si si on était bien adapté au terrain ce
genre de choses voilà après voilà il
faut aussi faire la part des choses il
ya la demande de logements qui est
importante il faut s'adapter à
l'environnement et essayer d'avoir du
bon sens par rapport à son logement
c'est pas toujours facile mais
maintenant on ne retrouve de plus en
plus cette démarche là notamment auprès
des architectes et même parfois chez
certains promoteurs et ça permet donc
concrètement d'alléger sa facture
d'électricité de chauffage
oui tout à fait puisque en fait on va
bénéficier d'apports solaires gratuits
donc on est sur ce qu'on appelle nous du
solaire passif donc c'est à dire que la
lumière et le soleil qui va rentrer en
hiver à l'intérieur du logement ça sera
de la chaleur qui va rentrer à
l'intérieur du logement donc du coup ça
sera ça de moins à dépenser en gaz en
électricité ou même en chauffage au bois
comment éviter les surchauffes l'été
alors pour éviter les surchauffes
l'était il ya plusieurs choses la
première chose ça va être donc ce que je
disais c'est à dire de se protéger un
maximum du soleil alors voilà c'est ça
peut être incompatible avec le fait de
faire apporter un maximum de soleil en
hiver mais ce que je disais donc c'est
que en mettant des casquettes solaire on
va avoir le soleil qui va éviter qu'il
ne rentrera plus à l'intérieur du
logement également on va se protéger
avec de la végétation devant la façade
sud qui va nous permettre en était de se
protéger parce que on aura une
végétation qui sera fenu tout fut
également ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va essayer de minimiser notre impact
humain à l'intérieur du logement c'est à
dire en évitant un maximum d'allumer les
lumières de de fin d' allumer les
lumières d'avoir des appareils
électroménagers à l'intérieur du
logement qui consomment trop d'énergie
et puis il ya un dernier aspect qui est
important c'est ce qu'on appelle la
surventilation nocturne c'est à dire de
fermer un maximum la maison la journée
quand le soleil est présent et de
l'ouvrir la nuit quand le soleil n'est
plus présent pour pouvoir aéré et
ventilés fortement et rafraîchir le
logement d'accord ça implique aussi une
isolation intelligente j'ai envie de
dire intérieur extérieur de la bâtisse
alors l'habitat bio climatique passe
aussi par également en effet une une
forte isolation en effet c'est pas
uniquement l'environnement et
l'implantation qui va jouer c'est aussi
de conserver un maximum la chaleur en
hiver et d'éviter que cette chaleur
rentrer en été ça passe également donc
du coup par une bonne isolation qu'elle
soit une bonne isolation hivernale et
une bonne isolation pour l'été est ce
que ces nouvelles ces nouveaux habitat
bioclimatique
engendre un coût supérieur aux maisons
fait à quel nom alors si on parle de
construction neuve non puisque en fait
en construction neuve aujourd'hui depuis
le 1er janvier de l'année 2013 nous
sommes sous la réglementation thermique
2012 et la réglementation thermique 2012
réintègre des aspects bioclimatique dans
le cadre des constructions de maisons
voilà si on parle de rénovation ça
dépend comment la maison a été
construite si la maison en effet a été
construite en ayant toutes les
orientations au nord ou ce genre de
choses en effet il va falloir
retravailler sur la maison et réaménager
les pièces pour re pourrait amener les
espaces de vie vers le sud parce qu'il
faut pas raser la maison plus globalisé
la maison en fait vous avez une chair et
s'est fait pas forcément non en fait
c'est après c'est un changement de
changement de pièces après les pièces
les pièces fonctionnelles cuisine salle
de bains où ce genre de pièce on va les
conserver là où elles sont après c'est
plutôt d'essayer de ramener par exemple
des chambres qui était au sud on va
essayer de plutôt de les décaler et puis
de faire le salon au sud mais après
c'est juste de la décoration en tout cas
en termes d'implantation et
d'orientation
merci pour ces précisions sur l'habitat
bioclimatique aura l'occasion d'en
reparler bien sûr lors d'une prochaine
chronique environnement qui va se
terminer ce soir comme chaque soir par
l'agenda oui absolument
l'agenda que devons-nous changer pour
qu'il y ait encore du poisson dans nos
océans demain l'association les
rencontres de poignées organise une
soirée débat vendredi 15 février à 20h30
autour du documentaire the end of the
line l'océan en voie d'épuisement des
spécialistes de la question seront
présents sur place et puis l'autre
rendrez-vous pardon une collecte oui une
collecte à des distributions annuelles
de sacs de déchets verts pour les
résidents des pavillons de montigny le
bretonneux auront lieu les samedis 16 et
23 février la collecte elle débutera
lundi 18 mars merci valérie prochain
rendez vous la semaine prochaine le 7 8
qui se poursuit nous allons continuer à
faire le tour de l'actualité locale en
ce 12 février